have you ever wished that you could make
your own perfect shade of lipstick
kendall
well now that you can do that at the lip
lab they will help you
through it they'll have you ready for
the mistletoe moment this holiday season
take a look
knock knock hello rocky how are you josh
i'm good
happy to finally get lip lab it's so
cute in here thank you we're glad to
have you here
i know you had your consultation earlier
with what it is about your pink
come over here let's take a look at how
it's going oh my god look at her mixing
it i know what do you guys do here
so it's a completely customizable
experience
we love to have fun here at liplab um
and you have a consultation with your
color expert who creates your custom
shade
you can choose the color a flavor a
finish flavor
flavor girl yes yes and you can also
name it and engrave it
so it's completely customizable okay i
love that you can actually engrave it
and name it because that makes the
perfect holiday gift
absolutely and one really great thing
especially right now this year since um
some families and friends aren't able to
be together
we do also offer virtual consultations
as well as virtual parties oh that's
amazing yeah so everybody can come
together and have that great holiday
spirit and have fun with us here at
liplab
um and who doesn't want a perfectly
customizable
gift for the holidays definitely
customizable gifts are always the best
oh absolutely
unique thoughtful and how do we do the
safety i know you mentioned
party room yeah absolutely so we do have
a party room um and everything is
socially distant perfect as well as we
have limited capacity as well as plexi
glass dividers yeah yeah
in between our guests all around yep and
color experts
we thoroughly sanitized before and after
each consultation
um and we are always wearing gloves and
masks perfect
now who can actually come here and enjoy
this experience everyone
anyone five years old 99 years old
man woman anyone i love that okay well
i'm ready to try my shade
yes let's do it have a seat and i love
the fact that it says
all lips have something powerful to say
oh absolutely so i'm ready i know mine
comes out of my mouth in this pink yeah
thank you so much alexis
yes
oh my gosh and as you can see our
formulas are very creamy very high
oh that looks really good
i love it it is the perfect pink and the
texture is
incredible i know all of our textures
are super hydrating
and the really great thing is we save
all your formulas on file it's never
going to be discontinued and you can
always reorder it oh never going to be
discontinued
that is music yes well thank you so much
everybody and happy holidays